two functions f and g are described
below which of these statements about f
and g is true so they defined function f
as kind of a traditional linear equation
right over here and this right over here
is g so this right over here is g of x
and that also looks like a linear
function we see it's a kind of a
downward sloping line so let's look at
our choices and see which of these are
true
f and g are both increasing and f is
increasing faster than g
well when i look at g well first of all
g is definitely decreasing so we already
know that that's false and f is also
decreasing we see here it has a negative
slope every time we move forward 3
in the x direction we're going to move
down 7 in the vertical direction so
neither of these are are increasing so
that's definitely not right f and g are
both increasing well that's definitely
not right so we know that both f and g
are decreasing so this first choice is
they're both decreasing and g is
decreasing faster than f so let's see
what the slope on g is so the slope on g
is every time we move 1 in the x
direction positive 1 in the x direction
we move down
we move down 2 in the y direction so for
g of x
if we were to write
our change in y over our change in x
which is our slope our change in y of
our change in x when we move 1 in the x
direction positive 1 in the x direction
we move down 2 in the y direction
so our change in y over change in x is
negative two
so g has a slope of negative two
f has a slope of negative seven thirds
negative seven thirds
negative seven thirds is the same thing
as negative 2 and 1 3. so f slope is
more negative so it is decreasing faster
so g is not decreasing faster than f f
is decreasing faster than g so this is
not right and then we have this choice f
and g are both decreasing and f is
decreasing faster than g this is right
right over here we have this last choice
g is increasing but f is
decreasing we know that's not true g is
actually decreasing